la dynamite soit faire torturer toi
qu'as tu remercies attention
[Musique]
et si le monde entier est à nos pieds
michael nous en sommes fiers
vous allez devenir médecin oui c'est ma
passion
christopher meyer crise est grand
reporter pour la société presque portant
un toast au vieux amis et aux nouveaux
à nice une femme très bien puisqu'elle
grâce à vous je me sens comme chez moi
elle est très attachée à toi ça se voit
ça devient très dangereux pour les
arméniens ici alors je veux tu pars tu
le dis si si je ne suis pas en sécurité
ici alors mon peuple et non plus je rêve
fan qu'est ce que la société presse fait
ici on rapporte les fesses de la guerre
ce n'est pas la guerre
[Musique]
personne ici mais sans résoudre qu'ils
veulent notre mort
[Musique]
il faut qu'on s'évade de turquie avant
qu'il ne soit trop tard je sus que vous
organisiez d'effets lire d'évasion pour
les orphelins
dites moi ce que je peux faire
[Musique]
est ce que tu aimes
et
un trapèze
c'est correct
il est accro d'espions
mon fils
[Musique]
ensemble nous construirons un avenir